my name is Alison Barth I'm a professor
in the Department of Biological Sciences
there Carnegie Mellon there are millions
and millions of neurons in the cerebral
cortex that all have specialized
functions and I've become really
interested in how we can take this pool
this enormous pool of neurons and
identify what each one of them is doing
and how their activity then enables
change between the connections between
these cells to encode our experience and
to underline learning and memory
we've been able to identify different
phases of learning and we've been able
to identify the biochemical and
molecular correlates of these different
phases so that we can see right after
some experience synapses are
strengthened but then they enter into
sort of a labile state I think
understanding these different phases
gives us the opportunity to potentially
manipulate the conditions of these
different phases to prolong to erase
memory for example or to extend the
duration or strengthen memories it's not
just learning and memory there are
diseases for example like epilepsy where
abnormal circuit function becomes
reinforced through a recurrent abnormal
activity and it's very likely that the
work that we're doing will inform some
of those pathological changes that can
occur in brain function and I think by
understanding the principles by which
circuits are organized we'll actually be
able to develop and design engineered
circuits that can carry out some of
these functions there's a lot of
biological insight that I think can help
computer science and engineering in
developing better tools that will
improve our existence as humans we use
the somatosensory cortex of rodents as
sort of a platform for understanding how
experience can transform neural circuits
and so we can use it to ask really
fundamental questions about how memories
are encoded in the brain we're using
features of our experience of our life
experience and they're somehow changing
in some permanent way or very
long-lasting way the circuits in our
brain recently we've become really
interested in developing anatomical
techniques where which we can classify
every single synapse
type amongst the 20 to 40 different
types of neurons that occur in the
cerebral cortex and so we'd like to
develop a directory by which we know
exactly how many contacts there are
between this type of genetically
specified neuron and this other type of
genetically specified neuron developing
labeling techniques where pre and
postsynaptic cells are labeled and then
we can count actually in real
the number of contacts between each type
of cell and then monitor those contacts
as the animal learns some sort of task
so we'd like to be able to dig into the
anatomy instead of looking in general at
it ask very specific questions about
who's talking to whom I believe that the
neural substrates for learning and
memory will be very stereotyped and I
believe that we'll be able to see to
identify when an animal learns for
example a task or when we have some
perceptual experience that's really
encoded in a long-lasting way that we'll
be able to identify the cells and
synapses that have participated in that
memory there's a lot of things that this
sort of cellular molecular analysis of
of memory can inform